The night desert has been embodied in a realistic worldview based on the 16-year-old developed Europe.
Here, with a medium called a sunspot type sword and a medium called a black stone, a
little fantasy castle is added, and the player goes on an adventure with the sunspot dragon without memory.
The game progresses with the story
Players can meet anytime and anywhere Now, with the agreement dragon, you can
grow together through adventure and
various villages can be melted into the
world through mpc.
Since it is small, I wanted to express various and sophisticated movements with the source.
Due to the nature of mmorpg, several characters must be drawn on one screen, so
I put a lot of effort into that part.
And I thought it was very important to react with the surrounding environment for immersion
For example, when climbing up a wall around you, or when characters
collide with each other
, and get on and off a horse or carriage, you
have a natural ability.  We
planned the maximum degree of freedom for the user toward the surroundings.
So, although a little bizarre and strange appearance may come out, on the contrary
, there was an expectation that it would come out more diverse and just as the users had imagined.
When a typhoon comes, the view becomes extremely narrow.  There was lice and development
. When the
wind blows, the hair blows and leaves are difficult. At
night, it is already strong and it is connected to the content as well as the change of lighting
.
This effort can be seen in other systems.
The space in which there is was created as a motif, and
you can see the purchase behavior of other players on the bib or ball in real time. You
can become close friends or enemies with the horse npc. In
Black Desert, the pc character focused on expressing the unique and natural appearance of
the novel.  case coat  It was possible to create a new look by emphasizing the technological decorations in the modern costume called "
Giant Ren", rather than exaggerating the trust of the giant, by
dividing and replacing each part severely
, it was possible to capture a sense of dew and a unique feeling even though it was not in the cabin.  More than 10,000
mpc are deployed in the desert.
They are all different depending on each region, and the productions using numerous animations have splendid
various cultural homes, from the simple appearance of a small rural town to the elegant appearance of a large city aristocrat.
In order to give the feeling of love there, we
made a variety of pc as well as fc to make the three more realistic
.
Every gamer has different security and opportunities.
We wanted to provide maximum satisfaction.
To this end, we provided a more realistic and free tool to decorate the character's journey so that they
could all be in front of us. In
the case of monsters, their own culture and
I made a form of
food. I like the fight where goblin fish is sacrificing drunken larynx, so there are always
aggressive and typical monsters, so various races coexist.
We made 5 hells of remittance with different characteristics
and worked based on a system that could complete a huge world as the area grew
It has been implemented so that there are no regions, and the naturalness of each region and the connected parts of the region is
poisoned. To move from one village to another,
even if it passes through moisture or grass, it can be reached by a smooth road or death.
We tried to satisfy you, and various
toms  I tried to make it a lot.
It will be a pleasant experience to climb a place that no one can climb or to leave a trace and find it.